Alors je ne vais pas vous le cacher, j'ai le cœur vide...
C'est assez difficile à décrire mais je crois que je n'ai jamais autant aimé une série et plus jamais on ne revivra quelque chose comme ça
Evidemment, nous aurons des expériences similaires,
il y aura d'autres séries incroyables mais jamais on ne revivra l'expérience : DARK
Je pensais à la base vous proposer, pourquoi pas,
un "3 Théories" : parler des mystères, des choses
non-résolues on va dire
Mais je pense qu'une vidéo sur
la fin de la série ce serait déjà pas mal !
Comme une sorte d'hommage à Dark, la meilleure série Netflix
Je vous encourage vivement à me partager vos opinions et vos via l'espace commentaire !
C'est dans ces moments là qu'internet est vraiment une belle invention
Afin de nous réunir pour parler et échanger
autour de ce genre de chef-d'oeuvre
Nous possédons tous nos émotions, nos perceptions dû à notre expérience personnelle et à notre vécu
Donc partageons ! Profitons ensemble de ce moment unique car jamais on ne le revivra
ALERTE SPOILER !! On va parler de toute la saison 3 donc vous êtes prévenus
Bon et juste avant de commencer par rapport à la dernière vidéo sur Dark, je sais que beaucoup ont trouvé ma prononciation des noms un peu bizarre
Mais j'ai vu la série en VO Allemande donc c'est pour ça si ma prononciation des noms est un peu différente de la vôtre, je ne sais pas comment ils disent en VF
Donc voilà ne soyez pas surpris si des fois je peux dire "Magnousse" (Magnus) par exemple ou autres choses similaires, Allez on y va !!
Donc finalement, le petit H.G Tannhaus était bien la cause ultime...
L'origine de tout le problème dû à la perte de sa famille, décédée tragiquement dans un accident de voiture
H.G Tannhaus construira alors une machine pour trouver une autre temporalité, une autre dimension où sa famille aurait survécu
Mais c'est au final sa propre réalité qu'il fragmentera en 2 autres dimensions : le monde de Adam et le monde de Eva
Il est vrai qu'au final c'est cohérent quand on s'y penche un petit peu puisque Dark a toujours fonctionné avec le Triquetra et le chiffre 3
l'Homme à 3 vies :
Quand il perd sa naïveté, quand il perd son innocence et quand il perd la vie tour court
Nous suivons toujours 3 âges différents, on voyage de 33 ans en 33 ans.
Toutes les symboliques sont vraiment fortes
C'est tout de même ouf que Tannhaus soit la cause de tout et qu'en plus ce soit lié à son désir, un manque, la perte d'un proche qu'il aimerait ramener à la vie
Je ne sais pas vous mais depuis la saison 1 j'ai toujours trouvé ce personnage décalé par rapport à Dark
Il n'était relié à personne, c'était
vraiment le personnage hors boucle.
On ne connaissait rien à la famille : Tannhaus et il s'est finalement retrouvé avec Charlotte sans rien demander
J'ai toujours pensé que c'était un choix de Hano (Noah) et d'Elizabeth de lui avoir déposé Charlotte, pour qu'elle soit protégée du monde post-apocalyptique
J'étais bien loin du compte ! Et p*tain, Adam portait finalement vraiment bien son nom
Absolument toutes les relations sans exception, chaque détails ont été créés et reproduit par lui à l'infini
C'est vraiment là où Dark c'est puissant !
Rien n'est laissé au hasard mais vraiment rien
D'où toutes les choses horribles et inimaginables qu'il a pu faire, tout comme Eva d'ailleurs
Alors, je pense que certains ont peut-être du mal à comprendre la fin de la série
Pourquoi tout le monde disparaît et on se retrouve avec seulement 6 personnages vers les années 2000-2005 à peu près
Et bien comme il a été démontré H.G Tannhaus a créé deux réalités qui n'auraient jamais dû exister, que Adam a façonné par le biais d'une et Eva l'autre
Etant donné que la réalité originelle a été fragmentée en 3, nous retrouvons donc les influences de cette réalité originelle dans les 2 autres
Le vœu "d'un monde sans Winden" comme mentionné par Katharina qui sera répété par Ulrich Nielsen tout au long de la série
Le ciré jaune, Wöller et son œil, les personnages en eux-mêmes...
Alors c'est peut-être personnelle comme vision mais c'est comme si on avait que des morceaux dans les 2 dimensions qui nous sont proposées
Des personnages qui ne sont pas entier, prenant que des aspects de personnalités du monde originel qui lui est entier
Comment bien expliquer ça ..?
Par exemple dans la réalité de Adam, Winden est constitué de "Non-dits" et de secrets qui deviennent lourd pour le scénario, puisque tout le monde cache tout
Alors que dans la réalité de Eva c'est
tout l'inverse !
Tout le monde s'avoue tout au bout d'un moment sans rien cacher alors que par moments ils le devraient
L'exemple le plus flagrant là-dessus est Aleksander Tiedemann qui dévoilera son plus grand secret à son fils Bartosz et qui souhaitera montrer les fûts de déchets radioactifs à Charlotte
C'est d'ailleurs un secret si lourd, qu'il n'aurait jamais dû dévoilé qu'au final, sa relation avec Bartosz a certainement été détruite à jamais, à cause de ça
Bref ! Comme si dans une réalité les
personnages étaient beaucoup trop honnêtes et dans l'autre plus timides, modestes car ils ne disent rien
Sauf qu'évidemment, une dualité ne mène à rien !
L'ombre et la lumière, le monde n'est pas tout blanc ou tout noir mais d'une infinité de gris
C'est pour ça que l'origine est la version complète !
Je ne sais pas si vous avez bien compris ma pensée...
Alors évidemment, pourquoi on se retrouve avec Wöller en couple avec Hannah, Bernadette certainement en couple avec Peter Doppler ou encore Regina ou Katharina ?
Et bien car comme mentionné par Claudia Tiedemann alias un des meilleurs personnages de la série d'ailleurs, ils sont hors boucle, hors de tout ce nœud créé et répété par Jonas et Martha
Et on en revient à ce que je vous disais : Le monde originel étant fragmenté, ce monde a servi de source pour les deux réalités, reprenant des détails déjà existants dans ce dernier
Comme Tannhaus par exemple qui est l'origine du problème. Dans le monde originel existe un H.G Tannhaus qui est comme un scientifique du Temps et de l'Espace
Comme il nous l'a été montré dans l'épisode 7 !
Donc nous avons un Tannhaus également dans les deux réalités mais en soit il est fragmenté
C'est une interprétation personnelle évidemment mais celui de la dimension de Adam semble plus relié au Temps, tandis que celui de Eva serait plus orienté Espace
Ce qui expliquerait pourquoi ils ont des machines à voyager à travers les dimensions
Par exemple, Adam et Eve portent ces noms car ils sont véritablement les premiers
L'union du Jonas de la réalité de Adam et de la Martha de la réalité de Eva a donné naissance à l'Inconnu
Cette personne qui se déplace à 3 avec 3 âges différents entre les réalités le temps.
Il a été confondu avec l'origine car il est celui qui donne naissance à l'abre généalogique de toute la série et ce dans les 2 mondes
l'Inconnu ou l'Uknown a eu une relation avec Agnes Nielsen et ce dans les 2 dimensions
Cette dernière avait affirmé avoir été avec un pasteur qui avait perdu la foi et l'Unknown a été pasteur un court moment de sa vie
Ensemble, ils ont donné naissance à Tronte Nielsen qui ensuite a eu avec Jana : Ulrich
Qui avec Katharina a eu : Martha, Magnus et Mikkel qui lui par le biais de son voyage dans le temps a eu Jonas
Jonas qui est donc le père de l'Inconnu qui donc se retrouvera avec Agnes et ainsi de suite, c'est infini
Absolument toute la famille Nielsen n'aurait jamais dû exister
Excepté Erna qui est la seule et véritable Nielsen ! Celle qui a adopté Agnes et qui lui a donné son nom qu'elle a perpétué à travers les âges par le biais de sa descendance
La famille Nielsen s'arrête donc à Rrna dans les années 1920 et évidemment... Agnes étant née de l'union de Bartosz et Silja... Et bien, c'est une relation qui n'aurait pas dû exister
Ensuite, la famille Doppler a été gangrené par l'arrivée de Charlotte et de Noah alias Hano Tauber, lui aussi fils de Silja et Bartosz
Charlotte a été amenée bébé à Tannhaus par sa "Elle" du futur et Elizabeth sous les ordres de Adam
Ce dernier l'élèvera et plus tard avec Peter, ils auront Elizabeth et Fransiska
Et une fois de plus, on est sur une boucle infinie entre Charlotte et Elisabeth
Aucun de ces personnages n'est issu d'une
relation temporelle saine, c'est pourquoi ils font parti du nœud et disparaissent
Peter est présent à la fin car sa présence est saine entre guillemets. La famille Doppler est implémenté dans Winden depuis toujours par le biais de Bernd Doppler
Il est le créateur de la centrale. Ce
dernier a eu un fils avec Greta Doppler, d'après le site de Netflix, il ne serait pas le père légitime car Greta aurait eu une relation avec un inconnu, j'avoue que ça m'a échappé
Mais cela ne change en rien la chose car Helge reste un Doppler ! Et du coup avec une femme hors de Winden, il a eu Peter
C'est également le cas pour Hannah qui est
issue de la famille Krüger, une famille non-issus de liaisons temporelles ou dimentionnelles
Pareil pour Katharina qui est une Albers. Une famille qui elle aussi n'est en aucun cas liée aux problèmes temporels
Tout comme Torben et son frère ou plutôt sa sœur Bernadette, issus de la famille Wöller, ils sont tous issus d'une famille dîtes : "normale"
Alors évidemment je n'ai pas parlé de Regina Tiedemann car je ne m'attendais pas à ce qu'elle soit autant une clé scénaristique
Claudia a finalement eu une liaison avec Bernd Doppler : l'ex directeur de la centrale dont elle a pris la relève et l'a caché à tous
Une relation assumée dans le monde originel. La famille Tiedemann étant hors problème temporel puisque Egon avec Doris ont eu Claudia qui avec Bernd ont eu Regina de manière classique
Et d'ailleurs c'est là où il pourrait y avoir un petit peu de spéculation car Aleksander n'étant pas relié aux problèmes temporels à la base, il devrait exister dans le monde originel
Avec certainement la même usurpation d'identité vu que son vrai nom est : Boris Niewald
Mais tout est donc modulable car étant
donné qu'Ulrich n'existe pas, il n'y a jamais eu de quiproquo sur la première fois de Katharina et Ulrich
Dévoilé soit-disant par Regina Tiedemann à la police alors que c'était en fait Hannah
Ce qui fait que ces dernières sont donc devenues amis et que Regina n'étant pas isolé n'a jamais rencontré Aleksander, vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Donc évidemment Bartosz n'est jamais né pour le moment et n'aurait jamais dû naître aussi et se lier avec Silja pour avoir Noah et Agnes, bref
Et vu que Claudia n'a pas dû disparaître à cause des voyages dans le temps et qu'elle assume pleinement sa relation avec Bernd comme on le voit sur la photo à la fin
C'est elle qui devrait être toujours à
la tête de la centrale. Centrale qui normalement a vu le jour sans souci puisque aucun cadavre n'a été retrouvé sur le chantier
Et donc aucun frein par rapport au Maire quant à la signature du permis de construire ainsi qu'une mauvaise communication autour du projet
Vu qu'il n’y a pas de morts cachés sur
le chantier et inexpliqués. Les détails du scénario sont très forts, rien n'est laissé au hasard, c'est parfait
Bon, je pense arriver à la fin de mes
pensées et je peux vous dire que ça fait du bien de se libérer et d'en parler
Alors évidemment on pourrait détailler des heures mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit très pertinent et ce n'était au final plus le but de la série avec cette saison 3
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser à Hannah enceinte d'Ulrich dans la dimension de Eva. Cela aurait amené de nouveaux personnages, une nouvelle descendance encore inconnue peut-être ?
Mais maintenant que nous avons les réponses, ce n'est pas vraiment pertinent de savoir ce que cela donnerait puisque la finalité sera et restera toujours la même
ou bien même l'union d'Helge qui a donné naissance à Peter, ce sont des détails qui n'apporteront rien au scénario tout comme Greta par rapport à Bernd comme je le disais
Je vous en supplie mais profitez bien de
ce moment pour partager vos ressentis et vos émotions
Car jamais mais jamais on ne revivra une telle chose
la hype est là, la passion est présente, c'est vraiment le moment
Après je dis ça mais peut-être qu'on revivra quelque chose de similaire dans 33 ans, qui sait ?
Dark restera pour moi à jamais une série incroyable, un véritable chef-d'oeuvre d'une qualité rare
C'est tout à fait le genre de série que je montrerai à ma descendance, en espérant que
mon fils ne soit pas mon père
Je vous remercie
sincèrement d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
Je vous souhaite le meilleur bien évidemment...
Le vide va être très dur à combler mais ça m'a fait vraiment du bien et plaisir d'en parler avec vous
Que le LionHeart soit avec Vous ! C'était Argorok...
Allez, au revoir tout le monde